what is happening during the referendum
on Sunday in Greece effects first of all
the Greek people but we are living in a
common currency area and fi defects all
other nations as well and the Europeans
as a whole and therefore it is quite
clear that the European institutions
make an appeal to the Greek people to
vote YES for the proposals of the
European institutions because we are
convinced that what was tabled by
jean-claude Juncker is sufficient stable
and sustainable basis for further future
cooperation in the eurozone it is a hand
stretched to the Greek people I repeat
there is no increase of v80 and middle
medical healthcare there is no increase
of EIT in energy sector there is no cuts
in pensions and in gauges the vote on
next Sunday is a vote not only about a
program and is fundamental to stay in
the eurozone or not I repeat that I'm
prepared to go to Greece and to Athens
and to discuss in the country itself
with people I will run and I will fight
to convince Greek people to take that
stretched hand of the Europeans and to
stay in the eurozone and to go together
with us